a brawl between two inmates left this
room blood-spattered despite the
significant blood loss no weapons were
recovered this was caused by women using
their fists probably the most common
factors for violence would include
homosexual type relationships amongst
the inmates personal clashes theft and
drug debts we combat it just like they
do on the street but drugs are here
drugs are in high demand they're
smuggled in through the mail and
sometimes even corrupt staff inmates who
get their hands on drugs automatically
have power over their peers and can
extort addicts for money possessions or
favors
the prison suspects Lili is one of the
kingpins she shows her power by having
other inmates do what she says are you
gonna go get us some water so we can get
some ice to dance though
I need some ice so you don't nobody too
much mystery or whatever well when they
do a song oh they know better if she
does deal drugs she makes sure not to
get caught on camera
she knows the prisoner watches her
anytime they hear my name up there old
Stanford drugs involved in drugs or you
don't label me like that because you
never found drugs on me in my possession
none of that so don't keep putting me
with drugs narcotics and stuff like that
and they always do Lieutenant James
Neely
heads the prison's investigative
services unit known as is you his
mission curb violence at Valley State by
stopping the flow of drugs appreciated
well a lot of our violence at Valley
State is due to drug debts and basically
drug trade period when inmates accrue a
drug debt and can't repay it just like
out on the street there's going to be
some violence that ensues the violence
encompasses more than fists the women
get creative on arming themselves we
find a lot of weapons but usually it's
more of a weapon of convenience throw a
lock in a sock and it's a simple
bludgeoning tool
you can tell by the sound that it makes
it's pretty hard melt or file a
toothbrush and it's slashes and slices
this right here is a slashing weapon
it is a toothbrush with a razor blade
melted into the end shove screws in a
lighter and it becomes a fatal stabbing
device I've seen women with their faces
slashed arms just basically all over the
body
[Music]